the 55th Annual Academy Awards
presentation brought to you by the Buick
Motor Division and your Buick dealer who
probably announced the 1983 Buicks and
Revlon trebla the people who helped make
the world a little more
and the towering video games and home
computers a tongue a leader in
entertainment and education for the
whole family and GE and GE we bring good
things to life our 55th Oscar show
continues with a man who adds dignity
and stature to any occasion mr. Charlton
Heston
Academy agrees on an appropriate
candidate these ceremonies include the
presentation of the Jean Hersholt
Humanitarian Award for those of you who
may not remember Alain Defoe the country
doctor who delivered the Dionne
quintuplets or some of the nearly 400
other characters he portrayed from the
silent era until his death in 1956 here
is Jean Hersholt
I think here is Jean Herschel
we lost the film
should we skip the zone yes never mind
Jean Hersholt was a wonderful man come
up to the house I'll show you this on my
tonight though we honor with this award
a man whose career as a filmmaker and a
citizen has earned him the regard of
those he works with and the gratitude of
those he serves he and his films have
been honored repeatedly not only by this
Academy but by other organizations and
governments here and around the world
but the respect and admiration accorded
him by his peers stems as much from his
tireless efforts on behalf of a many
organizations the public sector
organizations he served several of them
as president this Academy is one of them
others include the center theater group
the Performing Arts Council a motion
picture and television fund cedars-sinai
Medical Center and the American Film
Institute in the end though I think we
come to value a man not for what he does
but simply for what he is tonight I'm
very proud to present the Jean Hersholt
Award in those terms to a gentleman and
a very good man Walter Marius
Thank You Chuck I have worked in the
motion picture industry my entire adult
life I've been privileged to know and
collaborate with a remarkable group of
people I produce pictures of which I am
very proud and I'm preparing exciting
and challenging new ones the Academy
honored me some five years ago with the
Thalberg award and now this
in short this industry has been
exceedingly good to me
it has provided me with the opportunity
to realize many of my most deeply felt
creative and professional aspirations a
natural extension of those involvement
has been the acceptance of some of the
responsibilities of good citizenship
it's been a privilege for me to
participate in various professional
cultural and Welfare activities in this
industry and this community I'm grateful
for the opportunities have been accorded
to me to serve and I enjoy the
fulfillments and the friendships they've
brought me I recommend them to others
now thanks to Pat who encourages me to
Andrew and Larry who forgive me to
Marvin and Jesse and Harold and thanks
to the Academy and its Board of
Governors who continue to encourage
excellence in our films and in our
community
congratulations Walter thank you
that wasn't what happened I just found
out wasn't mr. Heston's fault they were
gonna roll the film cliff and then they
didn't nobody told him I mean it's
nerve-racking out here stuff like that
can happen to you it's so nerve-racking
in fact I think that at this point I'm
going to turn the podium over to
somebody who is I think probably the
most suave debonair attractive
statuesque always articulate man that I
know
mr. Dudley Moore
I must say such noise why I must say
I've admired the way in which you've
conducted the proceedings so far you
know I think you you've restored an
element of dignity to to a ceremony that
that has been in the past within a
hair's breadth of being a piece of fluff
what's that Plus flaw
hate it when that happens I know I've
missed you so much
ever since we did that film together no
no I didn't hear from you and you
promised damn right you do you didn't
call so we have arrived together family
children oh hello good evening
my pants are killing me I'm very
grateful to the Academy for letting me
be a nun nominated short subject
if
it's a great responsibility appearing on
a show seen by nearly 400 million people
in 74 countries two of whom I know
personally I'm relieved of one
responsibility this time around in as
much time as I'm not a nominee I'm not
bitter I don't have to worry about my
acceptance speech I don't know if you've
noticed but maybe no ifs winners never
seem to know when to stop they they're
always thanking people they haven't seen
for years mothers and fathers and for
some some tragic cases wives
god life and in some I've said that all
I'll say if it isn't too precise
gosh this is fun I'd like to suggest a
model acceptance for all winners
and in that hush moment the envelope is
opened and you hear over the pounding of
your heart your name called you leap
from your crouching position you grab
your Oscar you look at their agent
straight in the eye and say who needs
you
well after all that jocularity to
present the next winner
we welcome the handsome opera star La
Traviata
Placido Domingo and the glamorous singer
who proved her dramatic talent in come
back to the five-and-dime Jimmy Dean
Jimmy Dean cher Cher